hi guys welcome to the just pearly songs
youtube channel and today i'm going to
be reacting to magnolia by playboy cardi
before i start the video do not forget
to subscribe
like this video and comment if you think
i got my reaction
correct
[Music]
so it looks like he starts the video
he's got two lady friends
um in his bed looks like they get along
pretty well
i would say pretty well um and then
there's like a scene of him running i
don't know what he's running from
um i'm gonna i'm gonna continue
[Music]
hiding in my sock
why would you why would you be hiding in
a sock that doesn't
in new york hide it in my sight
[Music]
running from the car shooting
yo pierre you want to come on okay so i
know what's going on now so i learned
he's running from the cops so that's
what he was running from earlier
and he's shooting at these ops and ops
is another word for opposition
so there's a lot of friends there but
they're not actually
friends it's actually a gang
and so when they say ops it's like the
opposition
gang
cause i ran it let me talk
am
[Music]
so he's saying um that he runs the block
and that's like why he's got
issues with the opposition
[Music]
so he said that he's [ __ ] on your
[ __ ] so this is a theme i've seen in a
couple songs
apparently it's a flex to like go after
someone else's girl
i don't think that's a very nice thing
to do but that's
he's like letting him know that he can
you [ __ ] sound like cat
sound like cat i'm sorry
[Music]
i think he's trying to say that like he
doesn't ever
fold so i want to say like that's just
him saying
like i'm very brave you know i'm not the
type of person to fold under pressure
and like i'm not scared
[Music]
she's
so it looks like he's having sexual
relations
with a girl i don't know if it's like
the girl from earlier like the guys girl
or if it's like someone else's not too
sure
um there was some other stuff in there
too but i didn't really catch it
i'm gonna i'll keep going then i brought
my teeth hop up in the world
lucky in the world
[Music]
okay so there's a shootout that was so
weird
he just had like the guy had his arm
over him like they
were buddies and then they just pulled
out guns
why would you that seems weird and
there's a bag
so does did someone steal something
[Music]
looks like an auntie so i think that
means that your girl is
ugly i think that's what he's trying to
[Music]
he said he spent a hundred i'm i'm
assuming a hundred grand on a watch and
to me that's just not a wise
investment i would invest in real estate
that money at least grows your watch is
just gonna depreciate in value
like it just doesn't seem wise to me to
get a watch
[Music]
[Music]
i feel like he's not saying sock when he
says i'm hiding in my
sock i think it's something else i just
can't understand it
what what what what
rock like i don't milly rock
is millie a person
i'm not sure honestly like i i'm
assuming that just means like in new
york
i'm like a cool person but i've never
heard the
term millie rock before you say
rock running from the car shooting eddie
up
so he's trying to say his life is like
shooting at the opposition and running
from the cops
that happens a lot
yo pierre you want to come here [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
[Music]
well it looks like he got away from the
cops because by the end of the video
there's no um
he's not in jail so i'm assuming he got
away with it
that song i'd give it like a three out
of ten
it was okay um
it just wasn't like the type of beat
that i felt like i could shimmy to
like i like a beat that i can like you
know shimmy
shake my shoulders and i just didn't
feel like i could
bump with that to in the car like with
my friends
um yeah that's that's it i can't really
think of anything else the main themes
of the song
actually i don't want to forget the main
themes of the song were like just kind
of describing his life
like he wants them to know that he can
get
your girl um he also wants you to know
that
he shoots at the opposition he's not
scared and he runs from the cops so he
does not
he does some illegal activities i don't
know what
but yeah so three out of ten i feel like
i went over the main themes of the song
before i end the video do not forget
subscribe i know i've said it before and
i'm going to say it again
trying to move out of my parents house
please subscribe
at 10 000 subscribers i'm gonna do
something
i don't know what but it's gonna be cool
don't forget to comment
let me know how accurate my [ __ ] was and
three
like this video if you want to see more
i will talk to you guys next
time